hey so I'm here it's YouTube alive which
will actually be happening tomorrow
it's pretty funny I brought my huge
Nikon camera I brought my little other
Canon and I forgot all of my SD cards so
basically can't take any photos I can't
do anything but I got my flip so I can
do all kinds of fun stuff oh there's
some youtubers over there
yeah that's about it
so yes tomorrow YouTube life
that's set up here for you to live we've
got a bunch of people doing a bunch of
things
who's playing tour
Oh
let's see took live watch tomorrow I'm
actually gonna be on the Virgin America
flight so I'll be fronting live from a
plane in the air using their new Wi-Fi
service which is available on all of
their flights anyway that's it I'm out